[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm cabbie HD here
and these are the audio technica ath
m70x yes there's been a lot of curiosity
about these brand new headphones coming
out especially since the ath M 50s have
been so damn popular and these seem to
have an upgraded name and a bigger price
tag with an MSRP up over 400 bucks
although you can get them on Amazon for
300 bucks linked below so with the m70x
the number one question I get and
actually the easiest way to talk about
them is how do they compare to the M 50s
the M 50s get all this praise all the
time for being some of the most
incredible sounding headphones for a
very low price so now that the M 70s
come along for a much higher price
naturally we're all curious about if
they're that much better so with
headphones my comparisons can be very
simple I don't have to worry about
battery life or display tech or anything
crazy like that
it's just how they're built and how they
sound so with the build quality the m70x
are very simple and pretty similar to
the M 50s I'll be honest I was looking
for a bunch more metal or other premium
materials because I honestly expected
that with such a price increase but nope
it's all steel hardened plastic again
this time with a matte coat instead of
glossy plastic so it's a soft touch and
they have a pretty traditional styling a
pretty sharp tuxedo look here in black I
think they'd be much more interesting if
they offered it in some other colors
like the M 50s but that might come later
so they ditched the big bold Technica
branding on the top of the M 50s for a
much simpler subdued look on the M 70s
but this band here is still very
flexible it will suit all sorts of head
sizes although now it is actually only
padded in the middle where it actually
touches your head and overall the
headphones are just actually a lot
lighter this makes them more comfortable
to wear for longer periods of time
actually no that was a pretty big
complaint about the M 50s that there
were a little bit too tight the M 70s
still have a fantastic seal with even
softer ear cups and
all around them but they sit a little
bit lighter on your head now the only
one notable difference here with the EM
70s is that they don't fold anymore so
if you remember them 50s those could
fold up right on and just fit in like a
little travel bag with about half the
footprint of being fully expanded and
the EM 70s are lacking that hinge that
it needs to do that so you can still
swivel the ear-cups 90 degrees to lie
flat but that means you need a larger
case here that actually comes with it to
store them and travel and I guess that's
a pro and a con it's a con because they
are a bit bigger and it requires more
space they don't fit into quite a small
of a bag but it is a really nice case
that it comes with it's a high-quality
hardshell with padding on the inside and
this soft matte finish on the outside
that's pretty pleasant to hold so it's
free and it comes with in everything so
that's great
now you also get an additional cable bag
on the inside too I didn't use it that
much since I really only use the one
coiled cable but the m70 s do come with
three cables so it has a two metre long
short straight cable a three meter long
long straight cable and a three meter
long coiled cable so I use the coil and
most often like I said and they all
connect to the headphones via that same
new twist and lock mechanism that we saw
on the m50x so again it does mean you
can't really use any third party cables
if you wanted something colorful or
something braided or something like that
but the twist and lock is a pretty
secure fit and a high quality way to
connect your cable so overall yeah these
things are built pretty well but there's
obviously nothing spectacular about them
which I guess it isn't really meant to
be you'll see why in a second but of
course the most interesting part is how
they sound so I did a lot of listening I
don't know if I believe in the whole
burning in headphones or anything but
I've had these for about a week now and
I've been doing plenty of listening
mostly to music lots of it on Spotify on
my phone but then also plugged into the
deck on Mike and Peter and how to listen
to some higher quality audio files there
including actually mixing the last video
I did which was the Dell tablet review
and the bottom line about the sound is
this
these are studio monitors like for real
so that means they have a very neutral
sound signature which is what you want
if you're monitoring or mixing audio to
the untrained
here that may sound like it's lacking
base or even might be a little bit tinny
but you got to understand that this flat
frequency response is exactly what you
want when editing so the m50 s will
sound very rich because they do have
more bass in the m70 as they'll sound
way more colored and they will continue
to sound better for everyday listening
and music and movies and gaming and all
sorts of stuff like that but for
monitoring and mixing and producing the
even more flat sound and lightweight
comfort of the EM 70s is really what you
want now if we back up for a second the
M in m70x stands for monitors right so
closed back headphones but audio
technica actually newly introduced
something called the ath r70 x and r is
for open back reference headphones and a
lot of times when you step up in price
for audio quality like this you're gonna
want to move to open back headphones
it's kind of like moving two speakers in
your room that are right next to your
ears it's something that I can explain
in a later video but for now I think the
m70x is really the upper limit when it
comes to closed back production
headphones that you want to get in this
price if you've bought the M 50s or the
m50x already no need to worry I'm gonna
continue using and recommending them in
their ridiculously awesome price bracket
for their rich clear sound I use them
all the time for traveling and listening
but for production headphones I say for
the price the M 70s are starting to
compete with some open-back headphones
but if you absolutely must have closed
back monitors can't go wrong with these
so there you go that's the audio
technica ath m70x and a recap of the
m50x thank you for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one bass
[Music]